you know you think about mothers will do  anything for their child  and she used her last breaths to make  sure that he was  okay what does that say to you and what  does that say about nia well  sort of the same mantra she used for  life you know preservation  keep going when things are hard you keep  pushing  right it just shows you the strength of  the person how do you  talk to him about his mama and i see  that he asks about his mama all the time  he does i'll tell you um michaela and  ryan are doing a really great job  right tough situation um  especially because he was there it's not  like you're talking about a ghost  that's floating around right he's got  memories as well but  boy is he uh is he coming around right  really strong kid um  we we handle him and we talk to him  just like he's a five-year-old going on  sex  it's no different but when he wants to  talk about his mother we talk about his  mother  in conversation he's growing up and  handling it really well  you